right so much breaking news across the
country including multiple primaries in
Minnesota Wisconsin Connecticut and
Vermont along with ongoing congressional
investigations into the deep state
we have huge strong economic numbers to
give you tonight and much more but your
mainstream media just can't get enough
of amorosa for now the fourth day across
all platforms you're destroyed Trump
media highlighting what is the salacious
claims untrue accusations secret
recordings from yes amarosa a person who
was fired three times from a reality
show and by the way once from the White
House where she was hired by Donald
Trump and according to general Kelly
because of serious credibility and
character issues that's not brought off
air brought up very often and none of
them seems to matter to the crisis
peddler's seven days a week 24 hours a
day minute by minute hour by hour on
so-called news networks by the way we're
now on our 72 plus of what is only can
only be described as the Amoroso reality
show take a look
breaking news in our politics lead and
the ugly war of words between President
Trump and Omarosa Manigault Newman
Omarosa Manigault Newman Omarosa
Manigault Newman halt Newman yeah he
said she said between the president
Omarosa I'm a roast of Admiral Adama
roasting Omarosa Omarosa Amoroso
tomorrow sir Omarosa i'ma row say guys
buckle up
here is just part of my interview with
Omarosa Manigault Newman Omarosa
Manigault new minute Omarosa Omarosa
tomorrow sir Omarosa Omarosa morosa
Omarosa Omarosa
I don't think imma roast was anywhere
near any inner circle of the campaign
have to admit it's a little humorous but
this kind of obsessive anti Trump
coverage it's nothing new in fact this
echo chamber it never stops it just
moves crisis to crisis second by second
minute by minute hour by hour day by day
24/7 365 we've got the evidence take a
look now they will certainly face
questions about stormy Daniels the
stormy saga takes a dramatic turn
stormy Daniel streaming has learned he
haven't heard from him about the stormy
Daniels affair
film-star stormy Daniels breaking her
silence about her alleged affair with
President Trump we were talking I think
understandably and appropriately about
the most serious legal allegations that
stormy Daniels based told me Daniels I
am a proud polar no we are not all
created equal
at least not if you were born in as the
president put it a whole country the
word house instead of whole as in house
countries not whole countries I guess
he's a polar is there a difference if
the president said whole house do you
think these countries are poles Donald
Trump has turned the Oval Office into I
hope bowlers built this country 110
years ago these are the president
comments yesterday and today is no
different the compulsive coverage just
continues during the White House press
briefing and of course secretary press
secretary Sarah Sanders responding to
all of this a pretty powerful rebuttal
let's take a look unfortunately the
individuals in this room continue to
create a large platform for somebody
they know not to have a lot of
credibility for someone they frankly
refused to give a platform to when they
worked here at the White House it wasn't
until this individual started to
negatively attack this president in this
administration and try to tear this
entire place down that she received the
type of platform and rollout that she's
getting I think it would be great if
every single person in this room and
every single person in the
administration never had to talk about
this again and we actually got to focus
on the real policies and the real things
that not matter just to people in this
building but certainly all Americans
African Americans Hispanics and
everybody in between I think that would
be the best thing that we could
certainly do for our country and tonight
our friends the media Research Center
they're backing up what you just heard
from Sarah Sanders their research shows
that during their broadcast last night
the morning shows today ABC CBS NBC they
dedicated approximately three hundred
and forty four percent more time
covering amorosa than they did covering
the firing of FBI agent Peter struck
that's more than tripled the reporting
for salacious rumors over what is
serious news about what is a corrupt
high-ranking FBI official
fired because of his massive bias and
corruption at the heart of everything
from Hillary to general Flynn to the
beginning of the Russia Trump hoax and
today as he often does the president
bypassed the partisan press in the
country he took his message right to you
the American people he tweeted out quote
fired FBI agent Peter struck is a fraud
as is the rigged investigation that he
started there was no collusion or
obstruction with Russia and everybody
including the Democrats know it the only
collusion and obstruction was by crooked
Hillary the Democrats the DNC and
tonight a new report is now bolstering
the president's claim real clear
investigations they're showing serious
questions now being raised about fusion
GPS founder Glenn Simpson and the
shadowy Russian figures who attended a
now infamous 2016 Trump power meeting by
the way Robert Muller if you're looking
for potential Russia collusion we've got
more it's all right here and we all know
fusion GPS was employed by the DNC and
the Clinton campaign they paid the
multiple e to dig up what ended up being
Russian dirt on them candidate Donald
Trump tonight there are new concerns
over another client of fusion GPS well
that's the Russian lawyer who attended
that meeting that everyone's been
talking about she utilized Simpson
services to lobby against Russian
sanctions this plot just keeps
thickening and according to testimony
she had dinner with Simpson both before
and after the Trump Tower meeting sounds
like a setup to me and because Simpsons
relationship with that Kremlin tied
lawyer a Chicago financier named William
Browder was quote so concerned about
fusion gps's work on behalf of Russian
interests that in July of 2016
he actually lodged a complaint with the
DOJ let me put it simply Clinton's op
research firm fusion GPS was working on
behalf of the DNC Hillary Clinton and
also Russian backed interests so that's
right it's all literally represented by
the same person
Glenn Simpson that's exactly as sketchy
as it sounds but where's the hysteria
from the media this is about stealing a
president
election lying to the American people
with phony Russian information that is
paid for by the opposition party
candidate and then used for a FISA
warrant where's the Special Counsel
investigation oh it's not really an
investigation into collusion now is it
it's a partisan witch hunt against the
President and frankly you the American
people have seen through this and have
had enough even fake news cNN has a poll
that shows that's right two-thirds of
you the American people are now calling
for Robert mola to wrap this garbage up
and this comes as the trial of the
century may be soon be coming to an end
after 11 days the defense rested in the
bank and tax fraud case a Paul Manafort
from 2005 they didn't bother calling a
single witness man affords legal team
apparently believes that the special
counsel did not meet their burden the
burden of proof and they may be right
according to analysis from a northern
virginia criminal defense attorney james
other was not ready for primetime and
judge alice's courtroom quote no matter
how strong their evidence how righteous
their cause how impressive their resumes
may be and actually are they simply have
not done a very good job when clearly
Muller has and was trying to turn the
screws on Manta fort as judge Ellis told
us he never wanted to go to trial he
just wanted Matt afford to sing or to
compose so that Muller could give up
something or make up something anything
to then either prosecutor impeached
Donald Trump and despite team Muller's
poor performance in court sadly for Matt
affort the odds are stacked against him
the vast majority of federal cases
result in a guilty verdict over 90% this
case for the record and maybe we'll get
even as early as Thursday of this week a
verdict this case has nothing to do with
collusion nothing to do with Donald
Trump nothing to do with Russia nothing
to do with the election at all
rod Rosen's the Stynes mandate allowed
this and meanwhile what do we have
Hillary Clinton committing multiple
serious felonies crimes mishandling
top-secret information
she obstructed justice when she deleted
of course subpoenaed emails washed her
hard drives with bleach bit washed them
away so they can never be
found again broke up her devices with
hammers fixed and rigged an
investigation with Steel's dirty dossier
number that was full of Russian lies and
it was peddled to you the American
people why because they wanted to miss
inform you to steal an election that's
called propaganda misinformation
outright lying to the American people
and that information was then presented
to four separate FISA Court judges as
quote credible evidence nobody had ever
literally verified any of it
corroborated any of it nobody's been
indicted investigated by team Muller
regarding Clinton's dirty Russian
dossier this is a disgrace to America's
system of justice and frankly if we're
going to be blunt and honest here it is
a clear and danger to our clear and
present danger to our constitutional
republic now make no mistake manna forts
found guilty your media will have a
brand new obsession stormy stormy stormy
Blanco Blanco Blanco Russia Russia
Russia Russia and then of course Admiral
amorosa and again we'll be forced to
call them out for their shameless
Chrysler's penalty
yeah journalism in America is dead but
the real fear ought to be whether or not
we have a justice system that applies
equally Estus under the law equal
application of our laws this is really
about Russia why are we dealing with a
2005 tax case not related to the
campaign or Russia or Donald Trump at
all why aren't we investigating the
dirty dossier with Russian lies that
were peddled to the American people why
aren't we investigating FISA Court
judges that were absolutely a fraud was
perpetrated on their courts with Russian
lies what about Adam Schiff shifty shift
and he's talking to Russians on the
phone we played it for you what does he
want dirt on Donald Trump and now we got
fusion gps glenn simpson meeting before
and after with the client that met with
Don junior and company at Trump Tower
that the media's made so much of and
also Russia's a client of his also you
got to be kidding me you couldn't put
this in a spy novel and have people
believe this